[Musique]
avec voilà une phrase bien sûr on jours
hélène bonjour pauline dans la presse
donc le bilan de la tournée diplomatique
d' emmanuel macron qui s'est achevé ses
dernières heures en allemagne quel bilan
en tirez de la tournée du président
français en russie et en ukraine un demi
succès selon libération qui estime que
ces rencontres avec vladimir poutine et
volodymyr zelensky n'ont certes pas
produit d'avancées majeures concrètes
mais qu'elles permettent tout de même
une reprise du dialogue
demi succès ou semi échec deux mythes
indique site le figaro qui rapporte que
le président français veut croire que sa
médiation aura permis d'ouvrir une
nouvelle voie diplomatique
outre atlantique de washington post
exprime son scepticisme face à ce qu'il
qualifie de navettes diplomatiques
effréné du président français à l'issue
de laquelle le quotidien américain
d'ivoire peu de signes colloque que le
kremlin aurait changé ses calculs le
journal évoque une possible attaque à
grande échelle contre l'ukraine dont
l'envoi de navires de guerre russe en
mer noire pourrait être à 9 ans signe au
royaume uni de time ce pécule pour sa
part sur le départ lundi du port
allemand de hambourg du yacht privé de
vladimir poutine qui pourrait être liée
à la crainte de sanctions prises dans la
foulée d'une éventuelle invasion de
l'ukraine ce qui fait quand même
beaucoup de peut-être
effectivement direction l'inde à présent
elano l'interdiction du foulard
islamique dans des écoles du sud du pays
a déclenché des manifestations et une
levée de boucliers au sein de la
communauté musulmane est d'après jean do
le gouvernement du karnataka a ordonné
la fermeture pour trois jours des
collèges et des lycées de l'état après
que certaines manifestations dégénérer
l'opposition indienne fustige elle le
gouvernement donna reed rameau dit
qu'elles accusent de chercher à
transformer les écoles en champ de
bataille je cite alors que l'inde
s'apprête à commémorer les 20 ans des
émeutes anti musulmane du gujarat qui
avait fait à l'époque plus d'un millier
de morts alors que narendra modi était
alors le chef du gouvernement local et
avait été accusé d'avoir des libérez
m'en laisser faire les émeutiers de
telegraaf india fait état des critiques
croissantes à l'égard du premier
ministre sur son autoritarisme et sa
politique de discrimination envers les
minorités religieuses ce qui s'est passé
au gujarat en 2002 n'a été que le
premier événement d'une longue série
c'est à partir de ce moment là que
colporter des préjugés n'a plus été
honteux que brandir le sectarisme sur la
scène publique et en tirer profit a
commencé à être une source de fierté ce
spectacle n'est pas terminé son
principal protagoniste entendait naréna
maudit ne fait que s'échauffer continuer
à regarder parce que fermer les yeux
n'atténuera pas l'abomination je cite de
ce que nous sommes devenus l'afrique de
l'ouest est elle devenue le paradis des
narcotrafiquants l'onu en tout cas
affirment qu'elle est devenue la
première voie du trafic de cocaïne vers
l'europe la croix parle d'une situation
hors de contrôle dont témoignerait la
multiplication des saisies record comme
pendant la première semaine de janvier
au plus de 200 kilos de cocaïne ont été
saisis dans la voiture d'un élu local du
nord du niger le journal évoque parmi
les causes de l'intensification de ce
trafic l'effondrement de la libye en
2011 qui aurait facilité la
sanctuarisation des routes de la drogue
en direction de l'europe via le sahel
lacroix précise que la cocaïne qui ait
produites et exportées d'amérique latine
par voie maritime et aérienne entre sur
le continent principalement par la
guinée-bissau ce tout petit pays
d'afrique de l'ouest souvent qualifié de
narco état a été le théâtre de plusieurs
coups de force depuis une dizaine
d'années le dernier en date a eu lieu le
1er février un coup d'état très étrange
selon le daily mail rixe était par
courrier international le journal sud
africain évoque un genre de putsch très
différent de la récente série de coups
d'état en afrique de l'ouest est très
probablement lié précisément à la
profonde implication de ce pays dans le
trafic de drogue un putsch qui a échoué
en l'occurrence on ne se quittent pas
là-dessus hélène rien de tel que de
parler chiffons n'est ce pas pauline
pour se changer en les idées après la
mode des chaussures moche on le voit pas
vraiment c'est dommage la mode paraît-il
des vêtements inspirés du rayon
alimentation comme cette fabuleuse robe
croissant porté par l'actrice gesa
jusqu'à parker dans le dernier épisode
de la série and just like dat il y avait
aussi le petit sac tour eiffel a sorti
so frenchy le croyez moi sur parole
s'est accroupi j'espère qu'on le verra
tout à leur merci beaucoup